[Musique]
le Salon des Seniors premier du nom a
été inauguré en présence de la
conseillère départementale en charge des
personnes âgées Marie Bala un salon pour
permettre au seniors de la Réunion
d'obtenir un maximum d'informations sur
leur
droit comment faire pour comment faire
pour tout simplement bienveillir je vous
souhaite la bienvenue ce salon a été le
fruit d'un constat donc notamment en
voyant mes parents mes propres parents
vieillir les personnes autô de moi qui
vieillissent et le manque de visibilité
qu'ils ont notamment à trouver
l'information sur comment rendre
beaucoup plus accessible ma maison
comment avoir une retraite beaucoup plus
confortable et cetera le Conseil
départemental dont la compétence
principale est justement d'accompagner
les personnes âgées pour qu'ils
vieillissent le mieux possible était
présent ce salon la collectivité qui met
en place plusieurs dispositifs pour
faciliter le quotidien des personnes
âgées comme la location personnelle is
d'autonomie la PA le chèque santé le
Pass loisir ou encore le Pass transport
veut développer désormais les maisons
d'assistants
familiaux le projet de mandature le plus
important pour les personnes âgées donc
c'est la création de MAF c'est-à-dire
les maisons d'accueil familiaux qui vont
être créé parce que c'est une maison qui
seront qui sera donc de taille humaine
pour une capacité à peu près de 12
personnes âgées ce qui veut dire que le
gramoun au lieu bon les les institutions
sont saturé tandis que les maisons
d'accueil familiaux le gramoun reste
dans un accueil familial comme il a
toujours été depuis toujours à la
Réunion une meilleure prise en charge
plus humaine pour permettre de favoriser
le bienveillir des gramoun c'est ça qui
est important et en même temps c'est une
lutte aussi contre l'isolement parce
qu'il sera accompagné donc desidents
familiaux formés pour s'occuper de cette
personne ces personnes seront là
peut-être
provisoirement pour pour une durée
peut-être d'un mois parce que les
enfants ne sont pas là ou alors ils
seront là aussi plus longtemps moins
longtemps mais c'est une c'est
l'objectif donc du département de faire
en sorte que c'est ma voit le jour assez
rapidement et certainement le premier
MAF en 2016 des cramounes qui sont venus
nombreux visiter les différents stands
de ce
salon parorte que la cont
nous fait le sport dans mon club 3e âge
un petitour visite un
pe voir la rouverture du salon
parallèlement ce nouveau dispositif le
Conseil départemental souhaite
poursuivre l'offre en famille d'accueil
une solution alternative à l'hébergement
d' établissement très apprécié par les
personnes
[Musique]
âgées